Transcriber: Ataa Al Ayoubi
المدقّق: Yahya Mansour
Assemble
السلام عليكم
حياتي كلها مبنيةٌ
على عشر دقائق بالضبط من كل يوم.
فقد كنت يومياً،
قبل نومي،
تلك الدقائق العشرة بينما
تضع رأسك على الوسادة إلى أن تنام،
وأنت تتخيل نفسك في أماكن غريبة، وتتخيل
كل ما تريده في هذه الدقائق العشرة
تخيلت نفسي مع توم كروز أحارب معه،
وتخيلت أنني أتناول العشاء مع ميغ رايان
قبل أن أتركها وأذهب لسكارليت جوهانسون.
هذه العشر الدقائق خاصةً،
كنت أتخيل فيهم كل شيء
أتخيل كل ما اتمناه دائماً،
دون أن أكون محرجًا
من أن يرى أحد ما يجول في خيالي، وبعد ذلك
بمرور الوقت كانت خيالاتي تتحقق
الفكرة في منتهى البساطة،
كُنْتُ واسع الخيال منذ صغري
كنت أشاهد االكثير من الأفلام،
واقرأ الكثير من الروايات.
وبالمناسبة لم أكن من المتفوقين في الدراسة،
التحقت بكلية الهندسة لكنني لم اكن متفوقاً.
في المدرسة ، وبعد ذلك في الجامعة
اختلفت الامور قليلاً.
كُنتُ من الطلاب الذين يضعون الروايات داخل
الكتب بينما يشرح المعلم، وأقرأ اشياء اخرى.
و التحقت بكلية الهندسة وتخرجت
وعملت في مجال الهندسة لمدة تسع سنوات،
ولعدة اسباب بدأت التفكير بأنني أود
بالقيام بشيءٍ أحبه.
أود أن أقوم بشيء اخر، أريد أن اكون
كاتب روايات.
الشيء الذي كنت أود أن أكونه منذ صغري.
بدأت أن احلم بأنني مؤلف كتب خيال علمي
وكُتبي موجودة في رفوف المكتبات،
وبالفعل كتبت اول رواية لي
ومن ثم بدأت رحلة نشر هذه الرواية
أريد أن أرى الرواية التي كتبتها
على رفوف المكتبات
عندما بدأت في هذا الطريق
ذهبت لأبحث عن دور نشر،
وكان الموضوع كالآتي
تعامل معي الناشرون المخضرمون بسخرية.
كانوا يقولون لي : “هل أصبت بالجنون؟
هل من المعقول أن تقوم بالتأليف؟”
لم يقولوا لي : “كيف تريد أن تنشر؟“
بل : “أنت مجنون
لقيامك بالكتابة في المقام الأول”
وبعد ذلك ذهبت إلى دور النشر الشبابية
وتعرضت للرفض بطرق مختلفة.
عرض عليّ البعض أربعة أشهر.
وأعلمني آخرون أنهم غير مهتمين
بنوع الرواية التي كتبتها
ولم يتبقى لي سوى دور النشر الباقية
التي تطلب مني دفع المال
مقابل أن ينشروا روايتي
نظرت عندها إلى الأمر من جميع الاتجاهات.
واكتشفت انه سيتوجب عليّ
التسويق لروايتي بنفسي
لن تقوم أي دار نشر ،
سواء كانت مشهورة أم لا بتسويق روايتي
ومن ثم ستعود الأرباح بنسبة 90% لدار النشر
و 10% للكاتب، في الدور التي ستدفع للتسويق.
وستأخذ دور الطباعة التي لن تدفع للتسويق
نسبة 60% من الأرباح
وعندها قلت أن هذا غير مقبول.
سأقوم بالطباعة بنفسي ثم سأفكر ماذا سأفعل.
طبعت ألف نسخةٍ من الرواية
وثم جلست أفكر :
“ماذا سأفعل بكل هذه النسخ؟”
لأن التوزيع للأسف هو واجب دار النشر فقط.
ولا يمكنني أن أقوم به بنفسي.
الأمر الذي كان حلمي من البداية.
وهو أن أرى روايتي على رفوف المكتبات.
عندها بدأت بالذهاب إلى المكتبات،
الواحدة تلو الأخرى لأجرب حظي
قال لي معظم أصحاب المكتبات الكبيرة
أنهم يتعاملون مع دور النشر حصراً
ولكن مكتبةً واحدة من المكتبات الكبرى
وافقت وأخذت روايتي
وقالت لي لأننا سنقبل مقابل 50% من الأرباح
بينما كانت باقي المكتبات تأخذ 30% فقط
أرادت هذه المكتبة 50%،
لأنني أتيت لوحدي بدون دار نشر
ولم يكن لدي مشكلة أبداً.
كان جل اهتمامي
هو أن أرى روايتي على رفوف المكتبات
جانب مؤلفات الكتاب المشهورين
مثل أحمد خالد توفيق وغيره.
صورتها ونشرتها قائلاً :
“قريباً في جميع المكتبات”
لا أعرف كيف ستكون في جميع المكتبات،
ولكنني نشرت هذه الصورة بهذا الشكل.
وبعدها وافقت مكتبةٌ واحدة أخرى فقط
على روايتي.
بعد ذلك بدأت بالتفكير فيما يجب أن أفعل
وبدأت بالبحث عن دور توزيع
واسودت الدنيا في وجهي
وبدا لي أن الأمور سوف تقف عند هذا الحد.
كنت مرةً في محلٍ تجاري كبير في القاهرة
ومررنا بجانب متجر “ميغاستور”
الحاوي على أكبر متجر لبيع الكتب في المنطقة
وكانت زوجتي معي.
في ذلك الوقت كنت متزوجاً ولدي طفل.
وكنت احتفظ بعدة نسخ من الرواية معي
في حقيبتي وحقيبة زوجتي وحقيبة عربة طفلي.
من باب الاحتياط، لأكون مستعداً
في حال قابلت شخصاُ مهماً.
قالت لي زوجتي : “ادخل إلى المتجر
واعرض عليهم روايتك”
أجبتها : “كيف ستكون لي فرصة في هذا المتجر
وقد رفضتني مكتبات أخرى أصغر؟”
فقالت لي : “لن تخسر شيئاً.”
فدخلت إلى المتجر حاملاً روايتي
وأخبرتهم بقصتي،
أجابوني بأنهم لا يتعاملون مع الكتاب مباشرة
بل مع دور النشر. وليس أي دار نشر.
بل واحدةً من إحدى ثلاث دور نشر محددين.
وكان على أيّ كاتب في مصر أراد التعامل معهم
أن يتعامل من خلال دور النشر الثلاث هذه فقط
ولكنهم قالوا بأنهم سيأخذونها ويعرضونها
على مسؤولة المكتبات، و ستقرر هي مصيرها.
مضى الأسبوع و كنت قد نسيت الأمر
ثم وصلني بريد الكتروني من مسؤولة المكتبات.
مسؤولة المكتبات في متجر “ميغا ستور“.
تخبرني فيه أنه تم قبول روايتي.
وأنهم سيرسلون لي أحد موظفي دور النشر
التي نتعامل معها حتى يأخذ النسخ مني.
وفي اليوم التالي لم يتصل بي أحد
فأرسلت لها بريداً الكترونياُ لأخبرها بذلك.
فقالت لي :  “تريث قليلاً.
لم يمض إلا يوم واحد.”
ثم بعدها بعشر دقائق اتصل بي أحدهم.
وعندما أجبت قال لي أنه اتصل من أجل الرواية
وقبل أن يكمل كلامه،
بحثت عن تاريخ المكالمات بيننا
لأن رقمه مسجل لدي.
وقلت له :“أتذكرني؟ لقد قلت لي مسبقاً
أنك غير مهتم بالنوع الأدبي لروايتي.”
فأجابني :“هذا غير مهم حالياً،
المهم الآن هو نشر روايتك  في هذه المكتبة،
وجميع المكتبات الكبيرة الأخرى في مصر.”
فقبلت الأمر طبعاً.
وكانت تلك لحظة انطلاقي في هذا المجال.
و نقطة التحول في مسيرتي.
وفتحت لي أبواباً من الفرص.
بعدها ألفت روايةُ ثانية وثالثة.
وانطلقت ورشة العمل الخاصة بي،
وأصبحت من أكبر ورشات العمل في مصر.
تغير مسار حياتي.
لقد اخترت هذه القصة بالتحديد،
مع أنها ليست المفضلة لدي.
بل تلك قصة الحب خاصتي، ولكنها شخصية
لذا لا أستطيع مشاركتها معكم.
أردت أن أروي هذه القصة لأقول لكم
أنه لو أتى أحدهم يوماً ما
وأخبر الذين يعرفونني، والدي مثلاً
أن ابنك مهندس الأتمتة المشهور
سيترك مجال الهندسة بعد تسع سنوات من العمل
ليصبح مؤلف روايات؟
كان سيسخر منه والدي.
إن حياتنا تشبه الخيال كثيراً
ما يحدث هو أننا نمشي في مسارٍ محدد.
من النقطة ألف إلى النقطة ياء.
و عندما لا نمشي حسب ذلك المسار نجد أننا
ندور في حلقات، وكأننا لا نعيش حياتنا.
فمسارنا هو من النقطة ألف إلى النقطة ياء.
وليس لهاتين النقطتين
علاقة مباشرة ببعضهما مطلقاً
لكن النقطة ألف متصلة بالنقطة باء والنقطة
باء متصلة بالنقطة تاء
والنقطة تاء متصلة بالنقطة ثاء.
وهكذاحتى نصل إلى واو وأخيراً ياء.
المشكلة هي أننا دائماً نسمع-
لو قمنا بعمل استبيان لِنرى مَن مِن الناس
يجد أن التخيل هو مضيعةٌ للوقت.
لوجدنا خمسة بالمئة من الناس فقط.
والخمسة وتسعون الباقون
يعتقدون أن المخيلة مهمة جداً.
إذاً ماذا عن نسبة الناس المؤمنين
بتحقق هذه التخيلات؟
أي أنه بإمكان المرء
السعي وراء تخيلاته من أجل تحقيقها.
نجد فوراً أن نسبة المؤمنين بهذا
هبطت إلى خمسين بالمئة.
ما هو سبب هذا الهبوط؟
لن تتحقق هذه التخيلات
لأنه لم يتم تحديد الخطوات اللازمة.
جل ما تقوم به المخيلة هو تحديد الهدف.
ثم تعطينا الحياة
الخطوات اللازمة للوصول إليه.
“لو سلكت هذا المسار سوف تتخرج
وسيتم تعيينك بوظيفة بمستوى معين
ثم بعدها سوف تترقى وتصعد السلم الوظيفي
لتصل إلى مكان المدير في يومٍ ما.”
هناك مسارٌ معينٌ نسلكه.
وفيه يجد المرء نفسه ضجراً ومتعباً.
وعند حدوث أي مشكلة
يكون قادراً على الانسحاب بسهولة.
لم ذلك؟ لأن ذاك الهدف
هو ليس ما يطمح للوصول إليه.
إنه يمشي باتجاهه بالفعل
لأنه هو الاتجاه المعتاد.
تعطينا المخيلة أهدافاً،
لكن كيف سنصل إليها؟
عندما يكون لك هدف تريد الوصول إليه
تجد نفسك قادراً على النهوض بعد الفشل
سيكون لديك شغف بفعل ما يلزم
وإكمال الطريق،
حتى تحقق ما تريد وتصل إلى مقصدك.
كيف يكون هذا الأمر؟
لنقسم الموضوع إلى ثلاثة خطوات :
الأولى هي أن تتخيل بلا حدود.
كأنك تؤلف روايةً خيالية
بلا حدٍ أعلى للحلم.
بعد ذلك ابدأ بتخيل-
حاول دوماً
أن تكتب روايةً خيالية جيدة.
ماذا يعني هذا؟
يعني أن تكون النهاية منتظرة ومنطقية.
غير عشوائية.
دائماً يكون أدب الخيال الجيد
سواءً في الكتب أم في الأفلام،
محبوكاً بطريقة تجعل الدماغ قادراً
على ملء الفراغات المنطقية.
منذ بداية كتابة القصة
نحدد فكرتها ونهايتها.
لا تظنوا أن تحديد النهاية يتم لاحقاً.
بل نحدد نقطة نهاية القصة في مرحلة البدء
بالكتابة.
ثم ماذا؟
ثم ابدأ رحلة القصة من البداية إلى النهاية.
قد تواجهني بعض المشاكل أو الفراغات
خلال التأليف،
عندهأ أقوم بملئها وإصلاحها
الواحدة تلو الأخرى.
حسناً؟
حتى أصلح كل شيء.
هذه هي الفكرة التي أريدها:
عندما تؤلف قصة خيالية جيدة،
يجب أن تحدد النهاية المرجوة.
وبعدها فكر بالخطوة التالية فقط.
من غير المنطقي عندما أكون في نقطة البداية،
التفكير في المراحل الاخيرة
والمشاكل التي ستظهر فيما بعد.
عندها لن أكمل الطريق.
لكن لو نظرت إلى المرحلة التالية فقط،
لدي حلم وأود الوصول إليه،
يجب أن أفكر بالخطوة التي يمكنني أخذها الآن
بالإمكانيات المتوفرة لدي حالياً.
وأبدأ بالقيام بها.
وعندما أنتهي سأنظر إلى الخطوة التالية.
لو متَّ غداً، ما الذي سوف أندم عليه؟
وما الذي كنت أتمنى لو قمت به؟
هذه ليست مشكلة حقيقية. لو متَّ غداً
سوف يكون لدي مشاكل أكبر أفكر بها.
لو كنت أعرف أنني سأموت غداً
ستكون مشاكلي أكبر من الأشياء التي فوتّها.
لكن المشكلة الحقيقية هي
أنه لو عشت ثلاثين أو أربعين
أو خمسين سنةً بعد.
وطوال هذه الفترة،
كنت تعيش حياةً غير الحياة التي تحب.
أو كنت غير سعيداً على الإطلاق.
كما يعيش بعض الناس.
هذا هو الجنون بعينه.
لذا حتى أحقق ما أريد،
لا يجب علي التفكير بالخطوات اللاحقة.
لأنني لا أعرف متى ستكون،
قد تكون بعد خمسين سنة,
يجب أن أنظر إلى الخطوة التالية فقط.
وأقوم بحلها، ثم الإنتقال إلى ما بعدها.
وهكذا دواليك.
بهذه الطريقة ستحقق أحلامك.
كل ما كنت تحلم به وتتخيله سوف يتحقق.
انظر إلى الخطوة التالية، وقم بما يلزم.
وهلم جر.
لدينا ثلاث خطوات.
تخيل من دون سقف.
انظر إلى الخطوة التالية فقط
ثم قم بما يلزم للتقدم إلى الأمام.
خٌلِقنا متمتعين بنعمة المخيلة.
إنها نعمةٌ من ربنا.
حتى نبقى حرين وسعداء.
فلا يجب علينا إهدارها.
ولو أهدرت ثلاثين أو أربعين أو خمسين سنة
بأن تعيش حياةً غير التي تريد وتحب،
ستكون قد أخطأت كثيراً.
مهما كان حلمك كبيراً أو صغيراً.
ليس من الضروري أن يكون حلمك كبيراً.
إحلم بما تريد
من دون حدٍ أعلى،
وقم بالعمل على تحقيقه خطوةً تلو الأخرى.
حتى تستخدم النعمة التي أعطانا ربنا إياها
ألا وهي المخيلة، وحتى لا تذهب حياتك سدىً.
أشكركم جميعاً وأتمنى لكم التوفيق.